Finland officially now as of this
afternoon a member of NATO she's not one
of the wider implications of their
membership yeah it's easy just to think
they're the 31st member of NATO but it's
actually far from that this is pretty
significant first of all it extends
NATO's direct border with Russia it's
only extra 800 miles but it more than
doubles the direct border which is
significant it's also Finland ever since
World War II has been neutral when uh
during World War II the former Soviet
Union invaded Finland but at the end of
the war it was agreed that Finland would
remain neutral to keep a buffer zone
between east and west and even just
before the war
finland's population less than a third
of them wanted to join NATO literally
straight after the invasion 80 percent
wanted to join and that's why you've
seen this Rush decision from Russian
perspective they've said they'll bolster
their defensive systems if they see NATO
deploying forces into Finland and it's
been relatively muted response but
actually that will be quite wrong to
misinterpret that Putin will be very
concerned uh about uh NATO expanding
because he didn't want NATO to expand
he's inherited quite the opposite and
also it's quite a long border up here
and if they do have to put military
forces up there he's actually hasn't got
enough military forces for Ukraine at
the moment let alone mounting uh defense
on that border yes Ian stoltenberg put
it you know peaked in today got more
NATO which as you said is the exact
opposite of what he wanted remind us how
we got to this point today interesting
just looking back so 1949 the first 12
founding members of NATO
um so include the us over there but the
point is that there's a huge buffer zone
here between the the west and NATO and
the former Soviet Union but of course in
1990 four of the um the Soviet Union all
of a sudden a lot of these nations in
between suddenly went we're looking for
security the key ones the Baltic states
here Estonia Latvia and Lithuania that
all chose to join NATO as a result we
had a direct border then with NATO
itself now of course the Putin's
invasion of Ukraine was deliberately
an effort stop Ukraine also fall into
NATO and massively expanding the and it
also showed the vulnerability of Nations
like Finland and Sweden which led to
their decision I think there's a note of
caution here though
um the use of the word celebration of
finland's accession to Nato in a way
there's an inevitable consequence of
Putin's invasion of Ukraine but there
will be consequences for NATO's
expansion not least of which that will
increase tensions between East and West
we don't have the buffer zones anymore
which have served us so well which will
increase frictions the president of
Finland said they're at the press
conference security and stability is
what it's all about Phil enjoying NATO
and Sweden as we understand will be next
what are the implications of them
joining for Global Security part of
Global Security and State security and
peace is about a stabilized situation as
soon as anything changes on the global
tectonic plates that can have unintended
consequences if we look at the sort of
broader map here the danger is you look
at NATO that's obviously Northern
Hemisphere a lot of blue of NATO
counters the red of Russia good versus
bad and the danger is it looks roughly
equal in reality Russia's uh population
its military its economy is a fraction
of that of the West um U.S budget for
its defenses 10 times the size of Russia
to put into contact so Russia will not
want to pick a fight with NATO let's be
clear but when the war in the conflict
in Ukraine is over as it will inevitably
end the challenge for Western leaders
will be to watch the new equilibrium
because at the moment we're building the
foundations of a new Cold War but we
don't have the benefit of the buffer
zones between East and West which have
served us so well for the last 80 years